[Musique]
la civilisation inca et mystérieuse et
fascinante
c'est un très très vaste empire aussi
mystérieux parce que il n'a pas laissé
de systèmes d'écriture derrière lui donc
c'est à travers la lecture et la
compréhension des recherches
archéologiques qu'on arrive à mieux
comprendre près de 500 ans après sa
chute pointe à callière lève le voile
sur cet empire en présentant plus de 300
artefacts rare et précieux on nous a dit
que on nous prêtait des pièces que même
dans le musée propriétaire et il n'était
jamais présenté à cause de leur
fragilité à cause de la rareté et ils
ont fait une exception
plusieurs téléspectateurs temps c'est
connaître la culture inca grâce aux
mystérieuses cités d'or
mais cette émission n'avait pas tout
vrai mais on porte un peu à tout et rien
donc sur le plan scientifique
on n'a pas été à la salle d'exposition
une toutefois effectivement il ya
plusieurs d'entre nous qui font un lien
direct entre les accords et la cité d'or
donc on évoque à l'extérieur des salles
quand même pour en faire un petit clin
d'oeil
l'exposition est riche il nous montre
que les tissus étaient plus précieux que
l'or ne servait pas de monnaie d'échangé
dans les cultures précolombiennes c'est
un objet qui va servir principalement
d'éléments symboliques pour représenter
le soleil alors que le textile au delà
de sa valeur symbolique est aussi une
monnaie d'échangé donc c'est la monnaie
de cette époque c'est aussi utilisé dans
les rituels religieux
autre belle trouvaille la section sur la
mort on y apprend que les incas parler à
leurs mots ni les plus anciennes ont mis
son pari égyptienne mais son du nord du
chili
mais la plupart des momies sont des
momies en fait qu'on appelle par
dessiccation naturelles dont la
sécheresse du paysage va faire que les
chefs vont se décomposer mais vont être
asséchées et si ça qui va permettre la
momification
les incas c'est le pérou cette nouvelle
exposition est une invitation au voyage
dans le temps ici n'est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal